un patrimoine architectural remarquable
qui au fil des années ses frites
aujourd'hui son clocher savut son parvis
et certains murs sont fissurés fissures
accentuée par le séisme de novembre 2007
alors l'annoncent d'une restauration
prochaine a fortement réjoui les fidèles
ça fait longtemps quand les paroissiens
attendent cette nouvelle donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle et en plus c'est une
obligation de de la fête de sainte
thérèse donc ça tombe bien les deux la
courbe du court j'ai vu marc robert
thomas domingo mignon tout ça m'apprend
cours depuis plus de dix ans nous avons
régulièrement des demandes des
paroissiens mais quand commence les
réparations de sainte-thérèse canton
masse des réparations de sainte-thérèse
il faut que s'intéresse redevienne la
paroisse qualité avant une annonce faite
en présence de personnalités et de
membres de l'église catholique
sous les yeux de sainte-thérèse celle
qui a donné son nom à cette église de
fort de france
à cette occasion donc une plaque a été
posée
accompagné d'une prière et d'un appel
aux dons
aujourd'hui le chantier prend forme et
les premières les premiers éléments du
chantier commence
dès ce mois ci le coût du chantier n'est
pas complètement balisé parce qu'il ya
des études qui sont pas encore terminés
qui ne sont pas encore faits mais enfin
c'est quand même chantier très très loin
j'ai envie de dire quelle enveloppe
risque de dépasser les 2 millions
d'euros ce monument important et même
essentiel pour l'architecturé
l'architecturé non seulement
martiniquaise mail architecture mondiale
et donc c'est important c'est un
bâtiment qui qui est un patrimoine
extraordinaire on se rend pas compte
parce que si chez nous on n'a pas
toujours la perspective
mais ce qu'ils ont en tout cas nous nous
disent et nous leur perron que c'est un
événement c'est un élément important du
patrimoine les fidèles devront être
patients
en ce jour de fête de sainte thérèse ils
seront là devant leur église sous un
chapiteau
les yeux remplis de joie
[Applaudissements]